i received my first call of an
individual over this
this four foot pedestrian rail your only
out you feel
is giving up your life the look in her
eyes
is they want to live but they can't see
how and they're in such
emotional pain that they just can't take
it anymore what will be the first thing
you would ask me
we've all seen it where an officer or a
citizen rushes up on a bridge and grabs
someone and pulls them over fantastic
great i want that individual
to come back over that rail on their own
so if you have the courage to come back
over the rail
you have the courage to fight and
continue on what got them to
jump usually when they let go for
negotiators
is not to look don't look down and watch
that body oh my gosh
many times it's the folks who have been
suffering for a long time they've just
had enough they're emotionally exhausted
and they can't see a way out
we want to get them some help but it is
difficult you know there's not a lot of
money put into mental health
sometimes they're waiting two months to
get an appointment with a mental health
professional i mean that's not right
if you're in crisis we need to get help
now
[Music]
my guest today is sergeant kevin briggs
23 years
chp veteran in the army prior to that
and he uh gave a talk on ted
which it was so powerful the bridge
between suicide
and life and then later on he wrote a
book called the guardian of golden gate
protecting the line between hope and
despair over 200 lives
were saved of people who were about to
commit suicide jumping off that bridge
which is known for suicide and and the
motivation behind why he wanted to
change people's life is very deep and i
want to really get into it it is
something that
a lot of people struggle with today
mental
anxiety panic um depression and and i
really want to hit up that topic and
that's not just in regular life people
go through it in business there's a lot
of people that are running a business
that are
running out of money they're by
themselves they're alone so i wanted to
bring him on so
sergeant kevin bricks thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment
yes sir thank you for having me absolute
pleasure so a
question for you i know the story i've
read it i got your notes here i've seen
your talk multiple times and
i've gone through it you know if you can
walk us through
your past all the way up to the first
time
you were able to save someone from
jumping off the bridge
if you can kind of give us the back
story there sure
right out of high school way back in
1981 i went to the army
into the infantry and was stationed up
in fort lewis washington for a year
and then i went over to germany and when
i was in germany just at age 20
i was diagnosed with cancer testicular
cancer
so i had my first operation in germany
they sent me back to san francisco
letterman army medical center where i
had two more operations
and found out that cancer had spread up
in my abdomen
so then i went through the chemotherapy
and you know how chemotherapy is it's
it's brutal i went down to 135 pounds or
so
lost all my hair really tough stuff but
went through all that took about a year
off lived at home with my parents
worked with my daddy at a printing shop
in san francisco for a bit
and then wanted to get in law
enforcement i applied several places but
i was
accepted by california department of
corrections
so i worked at soledad prison for a year
and then san quentin state prison for
two years
and when i was working at san quentin a
guy was working with us
wanted to go out for the california
highway patrol and i'm like and i don't
know he kept bugging me to do it with
him i got i don't think i could make a
man
away at all but i went through it and i
made it and unfortunately he didn't
so you got to be kidding
you know it's a six-month live-in
academy and i just worked my butt off
there i graduated fourth out of the
class
but i i couldn't believe it i just i
just studied study study gave up
six months out of my life to be there i
got to do this so
started out over by oakland california
many people have heard of oakland i was
in the east bay
in hayward spent a few years there and
then got back over to marin where i'm
from
and if folks don't know marin connects
to san francisco via that golden gate
bridge
so i didn't know a lot of officers did
not want to work done on this bridge
for a reason and i had crossed that
bridge being from marin i crossed that
bridge hundreds of times but i had
no idea that the number of suicides from
this bridge
and what people were going through most
people go there
celebrate birthdays have a great time
people from all over the world go there
so i started working on this bridge and
i i didn't know
what to do i received my first call of
an individual over the
this four foot pedestrian rail and i'm
thinking
i don't know what to say what to do i
wasn't trained for this in any way shape
or manner
young woman over the rail i just went up
and
compared to what i would do now was was
quite different because i didn't have
any training and it was horrible
and i'm thinking if she jumps is it my
fault am i responsible
so this was it sucked it really did but
i spoke with her
for some time i don't remember how long
it was i think she was on the verge of
being homeless
she had suffered from mental illness he
had a lot of things going on
but i did have empathy and so the look
in her eyes
which most people that i think that i've
spoken with
is they want to live but they can't see
how and they're in such emotional pain
that they just can't take it anymore and
i'll tell you they don't want to hurt
anybody else
they just can't take it anymore so
this young woman did come back over the
rail
and after seeing the look in her eyes
both over the rail and when she came
back this look of relief
but still scared and wondering how
things are going to go
i wanted to to study more and learn more
about this and talk to people who have
done this
i wanted this to be my craft so to speak
and that's what i did so eventually uh
way later in my career i did go through
the fbi crisis negotiator school
and that helped tremendously and i found
out some things i
i were doing that that was great and
other things that oh i really needed to
think about telling folks and and trying
to talk to folks about
so um that was fantastic but jazz what
were some of the things if you don't
mind sharing with us
sure like what to say and what not to
say and what i tell folks now
is things not to say like you should
calm down i understand and things will
get better
so if i'm talking to somebody say you
know what you should have done it kind
of slaps them in the face and these are
things that i
did sporadically once in a while but but
i really teach this now when i'm doing
my presentations
so you should calm down of course we try
to stay clear of that
you tell someone to calm down what do
they do they get mattered in hell you
know nobody's ever calmed down from
telling them to calm down i understand
what you're going through
do i really you know i've been through a
divorce i had the cancer i've had
head injuries multiple surgeries
a lot of stuff going on but i don't know
what that
individual has been going through can't
really compare it so much but if they
say you don't know what it's like to
have cancer
well i did we can talk about that
maybe some of the commonalities the
similarities in that and many times
commonalities will create comfort and
that's what we're trying to do is build
rapport
and then telling someone things will get
better um i can't do that really i just
i don't know i'm not a mental health
professional i'm not a doctor i
hope they will you know if they're
seriously contemplating suicide and
of course working up on the bridge
they're there but telling them at least
you'll have the opportunity for things
to get better
and then also why why'd you do that
it places blame on folks and really will
shut down that rapport that you're
trying to build
oh can you say that again so if you say
why did you do that it allows them to
blame
uh uh unpack that again it's like i'm
blaming them
why are you here why'd you do that what
are you doing that for
it tends to shut them down it really
does you know
why did you do that so don't ask that
question don't
ask that or even use it as a statement
that doesn't seem right
so we're really just trying to listen
and i tell folks 70
30 80 20 if you can listen for that
amount of time because a lot of us
including myself we tend to chat
too much we're not learning anything let
that individual speak if they want to
talk
let them speak it's fantastic they're
venting and we all know
that venting is wonderful for folks to
allow them to get everything out
what's been going on and we're learning
more about them so
let them speak so and then that and then
what did they teach you outside of let
them speak
was there for example let's just if you
don't my role playing
if you came to me and you saw me on the
bridge what would be the first thing you
would ask me
so here's what i would do let's say
you are over the rails standing on this
eye beam if that's that's over there
instead of me just walking up to you and
start a talk i'm going to stay about 10
15 feet back and i'm just gonna open
hand and go you can see i'm in uniform
i'm somebody of authority just go hey
i'm kevin is it okay if i come up and
chat with you for a while
and when you allow me to boom that
that's a great icebreaker right there
i'm giving you the opportunity
to allow me to come up because many many
times these folks have been kicked down
so often and told no no no you need to
do this you should have done that
by me asking a question is it okay if i
come up
and speak with you i think that sets it
for a really good tone
for that interaction and when you do i'm
gonna explain it i'm kevin briggs with
the patrol
i'm here for you today what's been going
on
i'm not gonna touch you i'm not gonna
grab you and we've all seen it
where an officer or a citizen rushes up
on a building or onto a bridge or
something and grabs someone and pulls
them over fantastic great
but i want to go deeper i want that
individual to come back
over that rail on their own because
imagine the courage that it takes to go
over that rail to begin with
now think and imagine the courage that
it takes
to come back over that rail yeah so if
you have the courage to come back over
the rail you have the courage to fight
and continue on and that's my thought
process on that
and and has it ever happened where
you've gone up and you have started a
conversation they didn't listen to and
they jumped off has that happened right
in front of you
yes yes unfortunately yes
how come they just want some time to
really
get it into their head and yeah
anybody ever makes it i remember i saw
one story where one gentleman made it
did you ever have any stories of people
making it or no
yes um i did have a guy that made it but
i was not there when he jumped i was
actually busy with another case so i met
him in the hospital
so they're they're very very few and
usually if they do make it
they have substantial injuries also when
you're there and
and and those who jumped what was the
tipping point that got them to
jump like what did do i'm sure there's a
commonality amongst those who jump and
then after they jump do you see a
reaction from them the moment they let
go
usually when they let go
um my heart breaks i start tearing up a
lot of times and
it it just messes you up you know it's
horrible when you're there
so what i teach folks now for
negotiators is not to look
because that fall that's what's going to
be in your head so i
when i talk to negotiators and those who
do this type of work
i tell them if it's inevitable or that
person all of a sudden leaps on you
don't look down and watch that body oh
my gosh wow i did
i did the times when i worked because i
wanted to watch i want will really not
watch but mark
that body because it's so treacherous
down there with the currents
so we we have markers that we throw and
all that but that's what's in my head
not talking to that individual but that
jump and that hit
and that's what's going to mess people
up later on down the line
you know you see a lot as as an officer
and paramedics
and things that's in your head and we
all
need to be able to continue to work and
do the work that we want to do
so kevin out of all the people that
uh jumped were majority men or women uh
men more men out of the 200 that are
suicidal to take their lives what
percentage would you say are men
male versus female oh i would say it
at least 95 oh you got to be kidding me
so majority is only men who are
so what does that tell you from your
study is the fact that
men are more willing to commit suicide
jumping off a bridge is there anything
to that data or it's just accidental
that it's 95.5
no i i think it really is it's guys
because
we don't come out and talk about what's
going on with us there's a whole variety
of things we think we're the
breadwinners we think we can fix
everything
we don't need help i can handle this on
my own and then it becomes
too much and you don't want to seek help
and you're only out you feel is
giving up your life
95 would you have ever guessed is 95
i would have never guessed it's 95.5
what what were some of the things like
you would hear for example is it
my my lost my job i lost all my saving
my wife is leaving me my kids don't want
to see me anymore i can't give up drugs
my
what what stories were the most common
stories you heard that got him to that
point
all of that once in a while it's a
criminal act
that they did i remember one individual
who jumped before we even got there
he had a sheet in his pocket he had just
got out of county jail from being booked
in for child
abuse so he didn't want to have to go
through that with his family and
everything he came right up to the
bridge and jumped
but the three things that i dealt with
most of the time was folks felt like
they were a burden they suffered from a
mental illness whether diagnosed or not
and if they had been taking a medication
for a mental illness
they stopped it sometimes prior or
sometime prior and that's huge if you
stop that medication we always hear
don't stop any medication that you're on
i mean especially true with mental
illness
consult your doctor there's side effects
with all this um
i've been diagnosed with depression i've
been through several therapies and
medications
you know some work some aren't that
slick but
they also have side effects and things
too so
many times it's the folks who have been
suffering for for a long time they've
just had enough they're emotionally
exhausted and they can't see a way out
they cannot see a way out of what's been
going on with them
what what gets them to come back over
and how long is that process meaning
like
from the moment you say hi i'm officer
you know briggs you mind if i come up
and speak with you
i'm not going to touch you i'm not going
to get close i just want to speak with
you
and then you start the dialogue with
them what's generally the timeline from
you start talking to them to them coming
back and not
not wanting to take their lives you know
i would save generally in an hour or so
i've had as low as 20 minutes i had one
that was a little over eight hours
on average it's an hour yes
and when that hour is done you're
drained you're beat you're exhausted i
bet
i mean i bet and how about the eight
hour when you you said six hours or
eight hours
eight hours yeah what case was that why
did it go eight hours
what was the challenge of that
individual um
i was working with the marin county
sheriff deputy on that one we would
trade back and forth
and this gentleman was a construction
worker and construction workers have a
high rate of suicide because of the
seasonal
thing and the high use of drugs and
alcohol and everything involved
in that but he would start to come back
and then he didn't want to he would go
back he was
he had issues with his wife money issues
all these different things going on so
it just took a very very long time
now on top of this working on this
bridge we generally do not stop the
traffic
so you got the cars going by you got the
noise it's
very noisy it's a really lousy place
to conduct these negotiations plus the
wind and it's always cold
it's a tough one it really is but this
that gentleman did eventually come back
over the rail and then we take them to
one of the local hospitals
to get evaluated is it a crime is it
considered a crime or no are they
getting arrested are they taken in or no
and that's a great question i i like to
talk about this one
um no it is not a crime here in the
united states in some countries it is to
attempt suicide it is a crime but not
here
and this is what i tell folks and i
think this is very very important
you see people suffering from mental
illness and then law enforcement comes
out and that individual is handcuffed
and people get all up in a roar about
this but i want to tell you something
that folks need to hear and what i would
do is i would tell
the individual in dealing with them when
they were over this rail or wherever i'm
at on the bridge
that especially let's just say over the
rail
when you come back over not if but when
you come back over
i have to place you in handcuffs that's
only for your safety and our policy
that's all it is you're not under arrest
you haven't done anything wrong
so most of the time they have not done
anything wrong they don't have a warrant
so if they come back over i've already
discussed it with them i've never had an
issue after discussing it with an
individual let me get this straight so
i'm on the
the individuals on the verge of jumping
i'm on the other side
not back where i'm safe while i'm on the
other side you tell me i'm going to
bring you over and i'm going to handcuff
you and they agree to it
i said when you come back over because
they want to know what happens because
now if they think
that they're in trouble that just
compounds everything
they think if they do come back over now
they're going to go to jail now that's
more money that's time away the
embarrassment and everything else
i'm going to knock all that down
and you know what here's what's going to
happen when you come back over first i
congratulate you and talk with you for a
minute
then i have to place you in handcuffs
that's only because it's our policy
but really they're in my hands now i'm
responsible for them
so let's say if i didn't put them in
handcuffs and i put them in a patrol car
and we start driving them down to san
francisco general
and we're going 60 miles down the road
and
they think you know what i don't want to
do this i really
should have jumped or whatever boom now
they're free to kick out the window and
jump out the car 60 miles an hour
whereas if i have them in handcuffs i
have that time to pull over at least
slow down a lot
so it is all about their safety but i
explained this to them and since
i've been doing that i've never had an
issue
kevin since you've been doing this and
you've gone through a few hundred of
these um
do you agree with the current law on
what to do after somebody is suicidal
or would you ever change it would you
change it like
they go get checked out and then the
people let them go and and they go about
their business
would you change the approach maybe they
stay somewhere for a week maybe the
timeline's got to be longer
what would you say because i guess the
main thing is you know the whole
uh what what is the award they use for
people who go to jail they get on they
get back in again recidivism
so how how often have you seen people
who are suicidal
they come they leave and they come back
and they want to commit to suicide
anyways because they didn't get the
proper need they need the proper
help they needed and that does happen
unfortunately
i would just hope and pray that the
individuals looking at them
really take this into consideration
they're there for a reason you know once
in a while we get these folks
who know the process and they're going
to go over the rail just because they
know we're going to respond
and they'll get three hots and a cotton
out of the cold and out of the wet in
the rain and all
but the vast majority of time these are
folks who are suffering greatly
and if they decide to live that day we
get them past this crisis
boom we want to get them some help but
it is difficult you know there's not a
lot of money put into mental health
um we need more funding for this for
folks to have
access sometimes they're waiting two
months to get an appointment with a
mental health professional i mean that's
not right
if you're in crisis we need to get help
now
you know and to build this and make this
a stronger system
was there ever anybody that was jumping
who was extremely successful financially
well off and
you know money wasn't the issue for them
or was everybody that you spoke to they
were all
dealing with financial difficulties no
it varied i've had rich folks poor folks
it doesn't even matter it it matter what
had been going on with them
and now of course i've seen folks who
had a lot of money and lost it
and they think that now they're an
embarrassment they're not going to be
able to keep up with the jones they're
losing their mercedes their kids can't
go to private school
they they think they've lost it that way
but i talked to them
and i remember speaking with one guy who
who was big in the financial district
and he lost
um mutual funds he was a mutual fund
manager
and he had lost people's money and and
he was about to lose his home and
everything else
uh he's up over the rail and i'm talking
to him we're talking about this and i go
well
he talked a lot about his wife and how
disappointed she's going to be and
everything else
and how he loved her and she did love
him and i said what if this was reversed
what if she was over the rail what would
you say to her
and he thought about this for a while
and i think that was the statement that
got him to come back
and then his wife actually met us at the
bridge because he had called her
wow very thankful
so sometimes i use this reversal if i
think that that may work
and it did that day kevin what else have
you used that's not what the fbi taught
you that's part of your
game plan that you use that's been very
effective
silence actually taking a step back
giving folks
time to think about things because i
think if i was over that rail my mind's
going to be a thousand different places
and i'm not going to hear everything if
somebody's trying to talk to me maybe i
don't want to hear it
but i talk a lot slower than i do right
now
because i think their mind is racing and
then i tell them after some time
hey i'm going to take a step back about
10 feet and give you some time to think
about everything
but i'm only going to do so if you
promise me not to do anything before
i come back up here and if they say yes
we have this verbal agreement
not that that means anything but i've
never lost one this way
and i'll take a step back and just let
them think about things
and that has really really helped folks
it gives them a chance to take a
breather knowing that i'm not there
because they're always i think if
somebody's over that rail they're always
thinking okay when is this guy going to
reach out and grab me
even though i tell them i won't but give
them a break give them some
some time to think have you had anybody
in your own because my question becomes
why
why do you have a heart for this is
there anybody in your family that's
taken their lives or no
yes there's mental illness in my family
my grandfather lost his life
to suicide i have a son who
battles with depression who was suicidal
who was engaging in non-suicidal
self-injury what we
used to refer to as cutting so this is
tough stuff and myself
having gone through this and
it's hard to understand unless you go
through it's one of those things
but to be inside the house and not want
to go out
and sit on a couch for days at a time
and not want to do anything and
and in your head you kind of think i'm
not productive i'm not doing anything
why is this i don't have the energy to
get up and do things i don't even want
to wash clothes i don't want to go to
the grocery store
i don't answer the phone you know this
is this is
it's brutal stuff so when if i can help
in any way
i'm going to but and now i want to get
to folks long before they get up to this
bridge or put a gun to their head or on
top of a building let's get to folks
now but what at what point is that so
you know
to me you know you're having your life
you're going through challenges boom
then all of a sudden you start having
problems problems and you haven't
thought about it yet then all of a
sudden you're like
you know what screw it is life really
worth it what's the purpose of life what
am i really doing and then you're
getting through
what have you noticed is the tipping
point to prevent them from going to the
next level
not even getting on the bridge like you
said right
it's that you have to want number one
thing in my opinion only people may
disagree but you have to want to get
better
that's the thing you have to be able to
recognize this or at least be willing to
speak about it and have folks talk to
you and say hey kevin i've been noticing
this you've been
staying inside all the time you're not
answering we used to go out for coffee
like right now with with guys i go out
for coffee at least three times a week
with
with some friends and we all sit around
talk about all sorts of different
subjects
for men women do this most of the time
already for guys it is so
so important to have this and sometimes
it's hard to make the time to do that
but it is so so important to get out and
have these chats
and we're not just talking about mental
illness we're talking about everything
sports hunting fishing
cars whatever it may be just to get out
of that that is huge but you have to
recognize it for yourself i have this
quality of life triad i developed and it
starts with ourself on the top
because many of us we give give give
give give
but we don't see what's going on with us
we fail to see that or what's going on
with our families
so we need to at least put ourselves
equal with what we're doing
with folks and if you use at the top
what are the other two right so we have
myself at the top
and then we have professional care and
i'm not just talking psychologists and
psychiatrists
anybody in profession whether that's a
yoga instructor a health instructor of
some sort
i took a keto for years with my boys
because they're half japanese
and that aikido instructor you know life
coach anybody in that realm
and then also your support system your
friends your family
social media that kind of stuff so
between all of that it's the building
blocks for you
on the top uh kevin what was
what what uh was your tipping point
where you got into
the hole and you were depressed and you
know and
in that state of mind are you feeling
helpless are you feeling like there's no
way in the world i can get out maybe you
help
us understand since you're saying if
you've never been in it you will know
about it what was your experience like
it is when you find that you just don't
want to do anything
you used to maybe you like to go fishing
a lot or maybe you're into hot rods
whatever it is
and you're not finding joy in those
things that you used to find joy in
go to the doctor find out what's going
on i went to my regular physician
and i told him i go doc i think stuff is
passing me by here i'm just not
feeling like like i used to you know a
long time ago
so he had me take this test and it's
called the phq-9
patient health questionnaire nine and
many many places use this
and it's it's a test just nine questions
and you take this
to see if you may have depression
so i took this test it only takes a
couple of minutes
he walked in the room with this he's
holding this and he goes kevin
you have depression how do you feel
about this and mind you i've had heart
issues i got three stents in my heart we
talked about the cancer
i've had some brain injuries and then a
divorce and
then all the other stuff so i'm thinking
depression on top of all this
but that's when we talked about some
medications and some different avenues
of approach
so that's a start and it's okay well
let's let's work on this
put yourself on top for a while i'm
looking at the questions right now i
found the phq9 test
on mdcalc.com first one is
little interest or pleasure in doing
things not at all several days
more than half the days nearly every
days second question feeling down
depressed or hopeless not at all several
days same same thing again
number three trouble falling or staying
asleep or sleeping too much
feeling tired or having little energy
poor appetite or
overeating feeling bad about yourself or
that you are a
failure or have let yourself or your
family down trouble concentrating on
things such as reading the newspaper or
watching television
moving or speaking so slowly that other
people could have noticed
or so fidgety or restless that you have
been moving a lot
more than usual last but not least
thoughts that you have
you would be better off dead or thoughts
of hurting yourself
in some way interesting list of
questions so those
nine gives a doctor an idea whether
you're depressed or not
it can truly help yes how are you doing
so just those nine questions you know i
highly recommend that to folks to see
how are you doing
what what the role did the church play
because i think you had one
disappointment
that you had with a church if you don't
mind sharing that with us
sure well i lost my mother to cancer
and she was just 49 years old when she
passed i was in my late 20s
and i was raised catholic i went to a
catholic school
and you know every week going to church
my dad would be on the pulpit speaking
he raised a lot of money
for our local church he was he was big
into it
but my mother was not catholic she was
protestant
when she passed away the church catholic
church would not allow her
to have a mass in the church and i'm
thinking my dad put four kids through
this school
he has raised more money than anybody
else for this church he's done so much
and you're not going to allow this
what kind of church what is i was so
angry
so angry and actually since then when
i've told this story i have had a
quite a few catholic priests come up and
apologize to me
one guy actually gave me an even a
little medal and he says i am so sorry
he goes that would not happen nowadays
but i was so angry and disappointed in
the church
what what year was this kevin if it's
you were 20 20 you said 25 you were 25
or
she was 49 she was she was age 49
and it happened she died in 1989
yeah just at age 49 you know it's brutal
watching someone die of cancer
we saw her take her last breath i closed
her eyes it's
it's tough what would you say to
somebody that's watching right now
you know who is uh um
you know i guess i would want to go
through a couple different people one
would be
you know you're going about your life
you're going a million miles an hour
things are you trying to pay the bills
you're trying to stay be a good brother
good
sister good husband good wife good you
know
parent you're trying to be a good
employee you're just trying to have some
fun keep your friendships
you don't notice what everybody's going
through what are some signs you see of
people around you and what approach
should
the individual take if there's anybody
around them that's kind of acting a
little different than they usually would
what signs should we look for i would
say watch for
talk behavior and mood when someone
talks to you
or are they coming out with what they
used to do or their activities different
and not everybody's suicidal we know
this maybe they're just going through a
tough time but let's find out
or are they talking about well you don't
have to worry about me next week i'm
you know nothing's everything's going to
be fine are they going on vacation or
are they talking about killing
themselves so talking about it what's
their behavior
are they sleeping a lot more or a lot
less
and i think people in a lot of emotional
pain what i've seen
is they sleep a lot or they abuse
alcohol or drugs
because when they're doing that they're
not in that state of mind
especially sleeping then um they're not
in this pain
so talk behavior and mood they seem like
they are depressed
with their behaviors are they giving
away belongings hey i know you've liked
this
this one particular fishing rod man i'm
going to give this to you why are you
doing that this is your favorite rod
and what are they doing if they're
talking about
feeling hopeless or being a burden
to their friends or their family so
things like this we look at that
the tbm the talk behavior and mood do
they seem depressed
what are their actions compared to what
they used to be do they seem happy
do they not want to come out of the
house they're not answering my texts or
my calls
well we used to get together twice a
week for lunch and we haven't done that
now you're you're making excuses or
you're not even answering the phone at
all
how are you doing now better
i try to stay busy and if i get into
this
bout of of depression or something that
may last some time
the thing is i know that it will pass
and also i know that there's things that
i can do i have two little chihuahuas my
first small dogs ever they're a blast i
tofu just by petting your dogs
10 minutes a day can can take a lot of
stress out of your life some folks like
cats or
whatever you got you know if you're into
horses and i know by stepping outside by
all right i gotta take these dogs out
for a walk i may be in a funk
but i take these dogs out for a walk and
they have a great time and and you're
getting out in that sun you're getting
that vitamin d
so i got a technical question for you do
and i want you to be as honest as
possible
uh do do people who like cats concern
you
i had a cat they they're destroyers
curtains
couches that cat cost me over two
thousand dollars
it's funny because when i present i pick
up a picture of my dog and then i put a
picture of one of those
i'm gonna say ugly cats all wrinkled and
all that hairless things it says
something like cats
there's got to be some humor here
somewhere in this whole presentation
because
it's a tough one if cats are your thing
then that's all right that's what it is
i mean you know i grew up with a grandma
who had 12 cats two dogs two birds
two parrots two snakes and my dad
my dad cannot stand animals
and that's his mom so his mom loves
animals
my dad hates animals but my dad's kids
love animals so he's not in the middle
he's in a bad situation and just a
bad place too because he's got two sets
of enemies one is above and one is below
he's not in a good place to be but i
agree you know animals do have a
big uh play a very important role you
know when you when they say
dog is a man's best friend you know
that's a last night i come home
from new york i land and it's midnight
by the time i come home i'm downstairs
in my office at midnight doing a quick
zoom until one o'clock in the morning
my two dogs are sitting right there next
to me just waiting right next to me and
they don't say anything they just fall
asleep but they're with me while i'm
doing my conference call
and somehow some way they help me come
with better content while i'm doing the
conference call because they're
just around you there's something
special that's fanta i do that same
thing i have this bed behind me this is
the spare bedroom and usually my two
dogs will
they'll be on the bed here waiting the
whole time but i didn't want them
barking and what kind of dogs you got
what kind of dogs you got new chihuahuas
ones that one's a risk that's right yeah
um and wow what a meat meat so sweet
both temperamental like if i put my hand
are they gonna bite my hand or no
because chihuahuas have a bad temper
they do but once they know you oh my god
you've never been licked so much you
never had a shower
they just look and they lick you all
right so much fun to be honest with you
i think chihuahuas need to
go get therapy they probably need to sit
down with somebody because i think
they're dealing with some kind of
depression or something
most chihuahuas i think maybe the most
depressed temperamental dogs i've met
in my life like even they'll look at you
if you get close to them
but i bet they're probably protective of
you so they'll protect you they just
don't like that
and they do they're funny my first small
dogs ever i've always had labs and
and weimaraners and different things i
got i got two massive
10 pound shih tzus i have very
intimidating you know and they sit right
next to me they look like big cats
as well that's that's what i'm dealing
with well well
sarge i got to tell you you know i uh i
also have had people in my personal life
that struggle with this
and it's unfortunate because uh
you you one of the toughest things to do
is somebody who says certain words just
because they want a lot of attention hey
i'm gonna take my life they're not gonna
do it but they want attention
and then those who are doing it and
they're not kidding with you they're
going to
there's the psychological torture of
when family and loved ones also use
form of suicide to immobilize their
family there's very different
dynamics there as well because you're
always going to sleep worrying about
what's going to be taking place but i
think it's a topic that we got to talk
about a lot because there's more people
who are on this side that are sincerely
not thinking their lives are worth it
and
you know one of the most common stories
you hear is when a person is about to
jump they'll say they got the
the i don't know how many people it is
that jumped who made it off the bay
bridge or the the the bridge in san
francisco the golden gate
who say afterwards from the moment i let
go i already regretted my decision
the moment i let go i already regretted
the decision
and uh half the time it's speaking of
people like you so for you to have saved
those 200 people's lives
you're a hero and i appreciate your
service well
thank you sir thank you very very much
it's it's absolute pleasure speaking
with you
pleasure is all mine the pleasure is all
mine thank you so much for making the
time
for coming and being a guest on
valuetainment yes sir thank you
take care one decision away from jumping
off a golden gate bridge and you have
this man here
sergeant kevin briggs who comes and has
a conversation with them saves nearly
200 people's lives
think about how many people right now
are going through challenges you know i
did a video a couple years ago
not even a couple years ago this got to
be six years ago
titled how i dealt with anxiety and
panic attacks for a couple years i went
through it myself so if you've never
seen this video click over here there
was a period all i was reading was to
understand
what is the difference between anxiety
attack panic attack
depression you know living in the future
living in the past how do you get them
to live in depression there was a
formula i needed to get
for me to calm my nerves and it worked
for me if you enjoyed the interview you
may also enjoy this video i did
six years ago having said that if you
enjoyed also subscribe to our channel
take care everybody bye